[Applause]
bunch of people yeah very nice people
here i hand-picked these people huh you
know something's been ours thinking you
see I have been in this studio before
but another under your Aegis he just
what yeah well it be wait doesn't my a
GIS look it up because I'm not sure they
all right are they under my rain rain
rain all right and you know I've done
this before when I've been on a show for
the first time hmm I like to stake out
the territory the way the Coyotes do you
know what they do I'm not exactly sure I
can show you so you feel that you're
more comfortable here and safer this is
your territory never been here before
and I'm a little nervous about it
so can I stake out my territory
[Applause]
you have any of you have coyotes in your
backyard you own dogs your own dogs I
fee member of the animal family will
stake out my territory oh no no please
no no mr. Reiner no
they add mr. Reiner berry my favorite
thing about that is you said who here
has the Coyotes in their backyard I
[Laughter]
believe it - yeah they are coyotes well
you're more comfortable here now
oh yes yes no I'm as a matter of fact
I'm less comfortable because that didn't
work active work hasn't coyotes bomb
with it - I'm telling you somebody said
that I had done that on another show and
I don't remember doing him they said why
don't you try it here and who is this
guy by the way let me find it by the way
try to forget that I ever staked out
territory forget the name we get that
man forget the word coyote forget the
word Aegis everything I want to ask you
something you've written a book and
congratulations on that we will get to
in just a second but very recently I saw
clip that fascinated me because of
course you're the creator and writer for
the Dick Van Dyke you know and I saw a
clip I didn't know this that you
originally we're going to play the park
van Dijk play we're gonna play I was
gonna play a character named Rob Petrie
Rob Petrie I think we all and when he
did it he called himself Petri so to
remain Rob Petri uh-huh no I was I did
it here in New York it was a pilot that
I did I wrote 13 scripts because I know
I was gonna have to act on it now and
when I did it that didn't sell it was
too bad wasn't too bad I actually saw
the clip it's very strange because it's
you
nananananana and then you walk in the
door it was it's very much different
theme but it somebody noticed that I
wasn't as good at playing me as somebody
else could be mm-hmm and no no Sheldon
Leonard who who saw the saw the pilot
and then read the 13 scripts and said
this should be done again I said never
want to fail twice with the same thing
do it once and get out I was doing
movies at the time and having a good
time writing them and he prevailed upon
me he said well let's get another actor
what am I supposed to he'll be the
producer and the writer I never did that
is you read the scripts you can produce
and
and if we hadn't gotten Dick Van Dyke
you wouldn't be inviting me to your to
your place to take out my time now in
your version in your version did you
trip over a no no I know I'm not the
physical comedian that even though I
tried to be in the dirt
why do you keep saying it didn't work
this audience back to up a hundred
percent on that bit the secret the
secret is pretend everything worked by
the way by the way your new tooth house
huh there was one that made me I was in
the dress room I laughed out loud
the pollution in the year 2000 this is a
very scatological show yeah all right
now let me ask you about the book yes
continue laughing yeah okay this is
actually it's a novel but it's very I'm
telling you did you aware this is a
novel but it's a it's it's actually it's
very autobiographical it's yes it's a
thinly veiled autobiography it's my my
days in 1942 2:45 I wrote in a book a
novel called enter laughing also when
Henley veiled autobiography which we am
a Broadway play in a movie and it was
about a boy who became an actor and it
was about myself
living in the Bronx working from
machinist and wanting to be an actor
going to the movies hello I want to be
Ronald Colman but there was already a
guy being Ronald Colman but and that is
Ronald Colman yes as if not there's a
lot of legal action I know the kid
changed his name to Don Coleman who
knows he loved it so much well I
finished that book finished in 1940 when
he was just stood on the stage for a
first time and fooled everybody who
thought he was an actor he's I fooled
everybody and I wondered what happened
to that kid and I realized what happened
to that kid happened to me from 1942 to
1945 I was in a Shakespearean touring
company then I was drafted into the Army
and I was an actor so this follows your
life for a yes this is this brings up a
good point this is a very racy book this
is a very sexy did you read it I read
some passages and one of the guys looks
for the I love the dirty stuff I see
coyotes the guys with coyotes in the
yard are cheering on dirty passages but
I read I was wondering is this just
seems uncharacteristic for you is it or
is it not I mean I didn't know you were
this kind of let me just say this to you
I married 52 years if you're not sexy a
little bit sexy or know a little bit
about sex and inventive about sex you
don't may you know Ricardo Montalban
once said of fantasy I want Fame yes yes
he once said his father I know I
remember hearing it when I was about
married 25 20 he says it's very easy to
make love to a different woman every
night that isn't it I'm not doing a good
Ricardo Montalban brie has a very fine
Spanish Moroccan accent rock and leather
and this is the important it is
difficult to satisfy one woman for 52
years 52 women every is very easy to do
so that's why I'm saying my sex in the
book is well researched well research
very well I'm nodding my head like I
know what you're talking about
I hope you do and talking to Conan
O'Brien here
[Applause]